[Musique]
alexandre romanès le cirque romanès le
dernier véritable cirque ziegler nh
authentique traditionnel revient donc à
paris comme chaque année à la même
époque vous installé square parodie dans
le 16e arrondissement juste à côté de la
nouvelle de la porte maillot avec un
nouveau spectacle intitulé les nomades
arrivent juin prochain un nouveau
spectacle aurait pu s'intituler les
nomades arrivent oui mais vous savez
qu'il ya une difficulté on a des
spécialistes qui prétendent qu'on a
toujours été en europe
quand on ne vient pas de l'inde que on
n'est pas des nomades
on a toujours été des sédentaires c'est
complètement stupide jusqu'au mot rome
qui ne veut rien dire parce que eux
gitans manouches bohémiens [ __ ]
et maintenant récemment roms c'est pas
du tout notre appellation
en fait je veux dire aux hommes mais
tous les peuples s'appelait les hommes
puis il ya eu un moment où les peuples
ont pris des noms il ya les gaulois
légèrement ne sais pas trop quoi
et nous on se retrouve avec le on
regarde le mot rom meinau devrait
appellation ces tsiganes pourquoi nous
avoir
et alors nos soi disant spécialistes je
crois qu'ils sont autant spécialistes
que moi je suis le spécialiste des
grenouilles et on nous sort ça
maintenant on n'est pas des nomades
alors qu'on est nous sommes des nomades
notre culture ne peut pas vivre dans la
sédentarisation ailleurs les egan qui
sont sédentaires je suis désolé c'est un
petit peu comme vous me dit tiens je
connais une famille de congolais vivent
en suède et ils font tout comme bien
suédois est ce qu'il soit encore
congolais c'est la question que je pose
je n'ai rien contre attention moi je
suis pas raciste mais voilà je trouve ça
assez étonnant qu'on nous dise que ces
gens nous disent on a toujours été là
vous voyez bien la tête et notre notre
langue et indiennes et moi c'est quand
je conseille quand j'ai vu le nom de
votre spectacle les domaines arrive ça
me rappelle un film je crois que ça a
été fait mais il ya dix ans
chez vous c'est un film sur la famille
romanès et sur son cirque
on va vous voir là et on va voir que
déjà à l'époque les nomades arrivent et
c'est quand que vous installiez ça
ressemble toujours à ça d'ailleurs
cette année elle va changer voilà les
nomades à brive extraits
[Musique]
com
[Rires]
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
[Rires]
on voit sur ces images alexandre romanès
que le cirque romanès rien à voir avec
les grands cirques que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont une une
invention américaine de la fin du 19e
siècle chez vous il ya un tout petit
chapiteau il fait quoi va mettre celui
qu'on va mettre 300 places ouais et on
est le contraire de ce que font les
cirques aujourd'hui met d'ailleurs à
définir vont mal il me montrait très mal
mais les chapiteaux aujourd'hui pas nous
évidemment mais les chapiteaux
aujourd'hui ce sont des hangars pour
avions mais moi je dis mais comment
qu'on peut faire un spectacle dans un
hangar pour avions c'est parti comme ça
alors nous on a tout fait à l'envers
oui y'a pas de faux vrai qu'il ya des
chats alors non il ya un chat et un
chien mais ils ne vont rien il ya
toujours la chèvre non y'a plus achevée
non j'ai pu la chèvre mais on a tout
fait à l'envers et d'ailleurs la fiche
si on peut la revoir sur la fiche il ya
le chapiteau il ya une corde qui voyait
la corde et regardez il ya ma chemise et
il ya deux il ya les culottes de ma
femme elle qui sont en train de sécher
c'est très classe et alors voilà et on a
beaucoup de monde on en a vraiment fait
autre chose on est resté dans
l'esthétique des gagnants mais elle
c'est du bricolage
est ce que vous êtes traité comme comme
les autres cirques ou es ce que vous
avez l'impression là aussi vous êtes
discriminer complètement c'est à dire
que quand j'envoie un courrier pour
demander l'autorisation de venir dans la
ville il ya à peu près
une ville sur deux qui nous refuse alors
qu'elle les accepte les autres cirques
ouais et je sais très bien ce qui pose
problème c'est le mood reagan d'ailleurs
quand on sait c'était très rigolo quand
on s'est installé dans le xvième on a eu
à peu près tout le quartier contre nous
et les gens disaient mais on ne les veut
plus il n'ya plus de chats dans le 16e
arrondissement ils les mangent elles
moi je leur ai répondu dans la presse en
disant vous avez bien vu c'est vrai il
ya plus de chats dans le xvième on les a
tous mangé mais puisqu'il n'y a plus de
chats maintenant nous allons manger vos
chiens eh bien ça ne les a pas fait rire
et qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on reproche
encore aujourd'hui au jigen pour vous
moi ce que je sais c'est que les nomades
sont mal vus partout sur tous les
continents les normales on sait pas d'où
ils viennent on sait pas où ils vont
qu'est ce qu'ils font les nomades font
peur et je pense que le problème il est
là
[Musique]
david ratte vous êtes auteur et
dessinateur de bande dessinée vous
publiez massy mon enfant chez
grand-angle c'est un roman graphique qui
se passe lui aussi dans les pyrénées
mais cette fois dans les pyrénées
orientales
c'est l'histoire d'une adolescente
amoureuse d'un garçon d'origine
maghrébine son père le trouve très bien
mais sa mère est une horrible raciste
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
raconter une histoire pareille
moi c'est un peu c'est un peu l'histoire
de ma famille quelque part je m'en suis
rendu compte après après sur le tard
mais l'histoire de chloé c'est un peu
l'histoire de ma mère en fait qui dans
les années à la fin des années 60 avait
une relation avec un antillais qui était
bon qu'il devenu mon père d'ailleurs
mouture france et laisse voilà elle ne
savait pas être je me suis rendu compte
en grandissant que ça n'avait pas été
super bien accepté par par mes grands
parents
ma grand mère qui était une femme
adorable que voilà j'aimais beaucoup
mais qui voit lavé des préjugés comme
les gens ne sont beaucoup de gens de son
époque et alors là j'ai exacerbée bien
sûr la situation et puis vous avez
raconté aujourd'hui la raconte
aujourd'hui ce qui change de ta balle
deux choses oui oui oui très sale et les
préjugés de cette époque là on en a
d'autres aujourd'hui mais ils sont pas
de la même sorte oui mais je me suis
aperçu que finalement dans les petites
villes de province parce que moi
j'habite voilà dans les pyrénées
orientales dans une petite ville de
moins de 10000 habitants je me suis
aperçu finalement l'observant mes
voisins que ces préjugés la existait
toujours
on parle pas de racisme frontale et moi
je m'attendais d'ailleurs en installant
dans ce genre de région qui est très
cosmopolite parce qu'on à côté de
l'espagne donc on a beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui viennent d'espagne ce qui est
vraiment une belle communauté entre les
entre les races et ont finalement pas
tant que ça pour elie saab certaines
personnes je veux pas généraliser bien
sûr mais certaines personnes restent
alors quand un peu un esprit de clocher
dans les petites villes comme ça de
montagne et c'est ce que j'ai voulu
exprimer dans cette histoire là alors là
on a une une adolescente une jeune fille
qui n'est évidemment pas du tout raciste
là un père qu'il n'est pas du tout non
plus elle a une mère horriblement
raciste est ce qu'on peut avoir une
épouse à six cantons n'est pas raciste
soi même est ce qu'on peut avoir une
mère raciste sans l'être soi même
ça me semblait même plus à se
transmettait plus facilement que vous
avez l'air de le dire dans cet album
alors heureusement ça se transmet
peut-être pas aussi facilement mais je
ne dirai pas qui démarre sa famille
voilà je dirais pas qu'elles
horriblement raciste parce qu'en fait
elle ne devient elle en tout cas le
manifeste parce que sa fille sort avec
un avec un maghrébin mais là des amis
arabes avec qui il s'entend très bien
d'ailleurs il ya une scène avec des
collègues de travail voilà où en est
fait pour elle c'est pas un problème et
jusqu'au moment où en effet elle
s'aperçoit que pour sa fille elle veut
pas ça donc c'est un racisme qui est
plus sourd je dirais que plus ouais
pourquoi les tél ça c'est une bonne
question pourquoi est ce qu'on est
raciste c'est la peur tout simplement je
pense que la méconnaissance et la
crainte qu'on a de ce qu'on connaît pas
créer créer ce genre de situation alors
après ces dix trouvent que c'est un
personnage qui est qui a très fort
caractère qui a mauvais caractère qui
est qu'ils sont filtre qui voilà qui est
déjà sans même sans être raciste elle
est un peu énervant quand même vous avez
voulu faire une bande dessinée édifiante
il ya eu une époque on faisait des
bandes dessinées édifiante c'est une
façon de moraliser les comportements
notamment dans la jeunesse
c'était votre but non j'avais plutôt
envie de raconter une histoire d'amour
entre finalement une mère et une fille
et justement qu'est-ce qui peut mettre
en danger la relation entre une mère et
une fille ce que cette femme
j'ai beaucoup de lecteurs qui la déteste
ma femme la déteste aussi ça serra et
moi j'ai dit gg j'ai une certaine
tendresse pour ce personnage grand-mère
vision mais les grands mères étaient
beaucoup plus sympathique que ça je vais
me faire incendier par la famille merde
c'est une femme adorable mais c'est un
peu c'est un personnage qui se trompe
tout simplement qu'à des peurs et qui se
trompe dans son combat et qu'ils en
effet une raciste et décrit un côté sos
racisme justement souvient il ya 30 ans
s il y avait comme ça les racistes et
les antiracistes était assez simple il y
avait bien et le mal aujourd'hui on sait
bien que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça les anti racistes se traite de
raciste entre eux on reproche plus aux
arabes d'être arabe ou leur reproche
d'être musulman et qu'on ne pose plus on
n'en fait plus un problème de racisme
n'est de laïcité
on leur reproche finalement leurs
croyances plus que la couleur de leur
peau
est ce que justement vous n'avez pas
pris ça à contre à rebrousse poil
quasiment peut-être peut-être en tout
cas je parle de racisme ordinaire ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le racisme
ordinaire qui n'existaient pas ou qu'on
n'avait pas en tout cas définis à
l'époque de ma grand mère de mon enfance
mais mais qui est très présent
finalement c'est celui qui s'exprime pas
forcément dans le voilà de manière très
sur la scène publique tonsure ni l'état
ni ses traits à l'eau une trop courts
denses en voilà exactement
alors justement il lui pose une question
- les îles habitées il avait vite les
parents à à dîner les parents du jeune
homme et elle leur demande s'ils sont
charlie wi et alors ils répondent non
vous avez pris un risque
je me suis amusé à ce que sinon ils
soient adorable tout ça on ne peut pas
faire mieux
ils sont sympathiques intelligent beau
charmant et paf y sont pas charlie
je voulais montrer qu en fait voilà on
peut avoir des opinions très différentes
sur un sur un sujet
j'ai dû moi je ne prends pas voilà je
j'observe des choses j'essaie de mettre
des gens en situation
il essaie d'imaginer comment il
réagirait alors il se trouve en effet
que la mère pose cette question à ses
invités c'est déjà la question a pas
posé quand on reçoit on a envie qu'ils
s'en aillent
exactement là elle met les pieds dans le
plat c'est le cas de le dire
c'est j'essayais d'imaginer comment les
parents d'abdelaziz dans l'histoire pour
répondre intelligemment à cette question
là tout en eux on ne ne reniant pas
leurs croyances et leur perception des
choses pour qu'ils expliquent en effet
que ne cautionne absolument pas
évidemment ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire il ya tout un dialogue sur cabu sur
même l'amour qu'ils avaient pour se
taire pour ce dessinateur là mais que en
effet pour eux le problème des
caricatures c'était voilà c'est un
problème pour j'essaie d'imaginer moi je
suis voilà je suis pas concerné parce
que je ne suis pas d'origine maghrébine
mais j'essaie d'imaginer en tant
qu'auteur
comment voilà ces gens là peuvent
raisonner et comment ils peuvent
apporter une réponse intelligente à
cette question là à une question qui est
complètement stupide de la part du maire
d'angers c'est la question qu'on a posés
au lendemain des attentats tous unis
comprennent des enfants de huit ans donc
passer au four l'idée quand même vous
l'avez située dans les pyrénées
orientales
c'est une occasion au fait vous vous
êtes fait plaisir à dessiner votre
village même peut-être sais pas si c'est
votre village qu'on va avoir servi les
bains j'habite panon j'habite pas amélie
les bains mais je n'habite pas très loin
mais en effet ce pour que c'est un
village qui est magnifique
j'aime beaucoup qui graphiquement voilà
je trouvais je trouvais intéressant et
est en effet on retrouve plusieurs voilà
plusieurs des cordes d'amélie-les-bains
de ces raids argelès-sur-mer enfin tout
c'est très joli vous avez dédié ce livre
est serge reggiani il est fait allusion
d'ailleurs à un moment à une de ses
célèbres chansons ma fille mais c'est
une chanson sur les problèmes qu'ont les
parents à voir leurs enfants vivre leur
propre vie au 22 c'est pas tellement le
sujet de votre
là pour moi le sujet était vraiment là
en dehors de la delà du fond sur le
racisme en f1 moi ce qui m'a motivé à
écrire ça c'était vraiment une relation
mère-fille et de voir qu'un enfant pas
prendre des décisions différentes de
celles une mère va aller dans une
orientation différente
et en effet il faut aussi dans sedan se
danse donné là que des parents moi je
suis père aussi d'adolescents à accepter
que nos enfants ont pas les mêmes
opinions que nous avons dans une voie
qui est différente de celle qu'on leur
qu'on imaginait pour eux et je trouve
que la chanson de reggiani et voilà
c'était magnifique audace à la
résilience parental faut avoir un petit
ami d'origine maghrébine c'est un peu
comme de vouloir être être acteurs au
lieu d'être médecin si vos parents
voulaient que vous soyez médecin
j'espère que non j'espère que non mais
pour une mère raciste c'est un choc
mais ce choc-là que je rate
[Musique]
sada freddy ndongo dit qu'ils sortent le
sixième album de daara j family
il ya ma télé daradji family c'est un
groupe de hip hop sénégalais il existait
depuis 1997
paris vous avez fait près de 1000
concerts un peu partout dans le monde et
aujourd'hui vous sortez votre sim
sixième album
on va regarder tout de suite le clip de
chaque coup et les sk des clés de
compréhension qu'il faut posséder pour
pouvoir
ça fourmille d'allusions j'ai
l'impression et nous on les comprend pas
de doute c'est vrai que ce sont des
codes et il ya pas mal de code comme on
fait beau partout dans le monde il ya
les codes d'enracinement qu'on peut voir
déco dossier futuriste qu'on peut voir
dans cette vidéo
et il y à il ya aussi la charte du mandé
qui est qui est aussi codifié
là où se trouvent nos grands boubous
blancs toujours mandingue et ses
serments et c'était la première jeudi
reddition constitution des droits de
l'homme qui a été fait au mali dans le
nord du mali et ça depuis depuis le 14
mai 2014 et où le xvème siècle et ce
sont des codes comme ça qu'on a essayé
un peu de enfin on a fait un patchwork
de ce que c'est que une sorte d'
afrocentrisme et d'ouverture futuristic
vers le monde vous regarde avant tout
bagage
[Musique]
jean marie bockel alors on voit qu'il
est question de retour aux sources de
transmission oui aussi je t'envoie l'ofs
c'était un rôle à jouer mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que chelsea écoulée
quand on connaît en train de chanter
c'est un peu chantée dans beaucoup de
pays et à la baie à la base ça vient du
ghana et c'est un appel à l'unisson donc
pour manifester autour d'un même foyer
alors quand on écoute tout votre album
on a l'impression vous attend on me dira
contre l'addiction aux écrans d'où le
titre d'ailleurs il ya ma télé il ya un
math et les c'est un personnage d'un
dessin animé
c'est une bande dessinée dans le voit si
nous tirons beau ce petit robot avec une
télé sont en vente sa date de la coupe
du monde de football de 80 de oui voilà
à gauche c'était le c'était la mascotte
en espagne depuis de cette coupe du
monde
et puis lui c'est le personnage alors
ceux liés à ma télé vous l'avez ressenti
comme il est très populaire au sénégal
les très populaires au sénégal je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque c'était avec la
avec avec l'espagne c'était en espagne
en 82 à l'époque il y avait les basile
boli tousart dominique rocheteau pour
l'équipe de france
et nous on était totalement câble et à
suivre les dessins animés et ses
personnages s'animent au ca de 11 pour
une coupe et ces personnages là était à
pouvait tout faire il pouvait être
serein dans caen et puisse prolonger les
bras et puis touché la balle de l'autre
côté on était tellement fasciné
et mes skis étaient remarquables c'était
la télé qu'il transportait toujours sur
le ventre cowboys et c'est aussi
aujourd'hui on a appelé l'album il ya ma
télé c'est un peu une autre critique par
rapport à ce que nous devenons
aujourd'hui lui transporté un écran sur
le ventre nous dans notre société
aujourd'hui chacun transporte un écran
dans les métros on se parle à peine
chacun a à peine baissé sur son écran on
voit même des foyers où il ya des
couples qui sont la côte à côte et
chacun et un parce que c'est comme ça
aussi au sénégal c'est partout dans le
monde
au sénégal c'est jeudi entre les
telenovelas les émissions télé
l'explosion de la téléphonie parce que
je pense qu'il y aura à peu près 600
millions de téléphones oui mais il faut
dire qu'en afrique on va payer avec son
téléphone aussi battez vous êtes allé
plus vite que nous le passé c'est allé
très vous voilà très vite et même les
papilles les moments qui sont dans les
villages tout le monde est apte ou non à
munich et tout le monde paie aussi
hachée et envoient de l'argent beaucoup
puisque nous en fait c'est un des plus
gros marchés en tout cas ouais actuelle
est donc et vous pensez vraiment que les
écrans rendre fous les africains de la
même manière que les occidentaux je
pense que c'est un cetain s'éteint c'est
une propagation
je dirais même général est aujourd'hui
avant même si on avalise l'afrique
on avait déjà remarqué qu'il y avait une
certaine addiction mais ce qui s'est
passé en afrique c'est à dire qu'il ya
une une évasion mais très très brutal
parce que en plus de 2,2 d'avoir
internet
il ya aussi toutes les toute l'industrie
téléphonique qui est venu en masse
s'installer parce que ils ont vu que la
démographie se développer assez vite et
que justement que l'afrique avait besoin
de réduire un peu le gap par rapport au
reste du monde même si des gens comme le
professeur phil woods a coïncidé chaleur
disent que l'afrique ma personne a
rattrapé la population a soif de de
toucher le monde de savoir ce qui se
passe dans le monde et même de
s'actualiser par rapport à ce qui se
passe aux etats unis est le rêve qu'on
aura déjà vendu qu on est à fond sur les
écrans on découvre qu'on peut
communiquer avec l'autre toutes les
trappes être formidable par exemple les
livres numériques ce dont souffre
l'afrique c'est qu'il ya pas de
bibliothèque
très très peu là peut-être que ce garçon
qu'on voit là une petite île en train de
dire s'expliquent justement le fond du
message c'est ça c'est que les jeunes
les plus jeunes en fait bad et qu'ils
ont accès à aux écrans bas ils vont ils
vont tomber dans l'est dans les villes
ils dérivent de toi de com de vraiment
aller découvrir le dernier film qui est
sorti le dernier sont dédiées etc
je pense que le fond du message c'est
que ces jeunes là doit profiter de la
technologie pour acquérir de la
connaissance parce que aujourd'hui on a
un google on a eu une équipe et dia et
cetera je pense que les en tout cas les
pics comme on les appelle les nouvelles
technologies doivent permettre aux
jeunes africains de créer des start up
et aussi de se développer de connaître
un peu mieux le monde quoi
chanson dans ce bel album dans lequel
vous expliquer que le pouvoir et
l'argent
ça rend fou plus particulièrement en
afrique où partout là aussi bas au
départ on a l'impression de croire que
sir en afrique quand on voit qu'il ya
une certaine dictature de temps en temps
et même des présidents qui veulent être
élu président à vie qui parfois sont
plus ou moins soutenue ou de manière
indirecte par par l'europe mais ce qui
se passe est qui et qui rigolo c'est que
on souffre du même syndrome partout dans
le monde
on voit qu'au départ les politiques sont
sympathiques et une fois qu'il
s'installe au pouvoir ils ont envie de
passation automatiquement donc c'est une
c'est une addiction au pouvoir qu'on a
simplement remarqué ça arrive partout
même chez les musiciens etc partout dans
le monde
quand plus on a de l'argent et plus on
en veut plus on a du pouvoir et plus on
en veut donc quelque part oui c'était
une ascèse que les jeunes africains
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils sont
conscients de ce dont on parlait avec
vert et zeitoun à savoir que toute
l'humanité via d'afrique
ils sont conscients de cela parce qu'on
a quand même eu la chance d'avoir un
très grand tom chez-nous cheikh anta
diop king qui a écrit nationale guy
culture et qui nous a même si c'est je
veux dire 1% ou 0 % il a permis à
beaucoup de jeunes africains d'avoir
cette reconnaissance là même avec
l'egypte l'égyptologie etc
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un travail à
faire parce que tout simplement comme il
le disait aujourd'hui les jeunes ils
rêvent d'aller en europe ils rêvent
d'aller en offre aux états unis et il
faut bien falloir qu'on n'inverse la
tendance et qui est en rien aux raids
africains au final quoi
[Musique]
jawad annour vous êtes journaliste et
vous publiez dieu est amour un
livre-enquête que vous avez écrit avec
timothée de rauglaudre chez flammarion
vous y dénoncer les associations
chrétiennes qui propose aux homosexuels
de les restaurer sont les mots qu'ils
emploient
alors les restaurer c'est quoi c'est de
les rendre alors hétérosexuels la
restauration c'est le mot qui utilisait
en fait pour parler de guérison il
s'agit de réorienter la personne
homosexuelle vers une scène
hétérosexualité
ou alors de l'aider à rester dans la
chasteté tout au long de sa vie s'est
inspiré des associations là aussi
souvent un chrétien évangéliste alors
c'est le chanteur s'est aussi inspiré en
fait c'est vraiment calqué sur le modèle
américain avec les mêmes penseurs les
mêmes écrits tant les mêmes écrit
derrière les mêmes livres qui est serve
de base c'est à ces thérapies de
guérison comme on l'appelle dans le
livre donc c'est vraiment un phénomène
nous ce qu'on montre dans le livre c'est
que c'est un phénomène qui est importé
des états unis et qui se développe en
europe depuis depuis 20 ans et alors il
parle pas de maladie les américains
parlent de maladie mais nous il ya en
france des lois contre l'homophobie qui
font qu'on ne peut pas parler de
maladies tout à fait alors c'est une
spécificité du territoire français en
fait les groupes se sont adaptés à sa la
cité française et évidemment ils évitent
de parler de maladie on va parler de
guérison des blessures intérieures on va
parler de restauration de l'identité des
personnes mais on va évidemment jamais
traité les homosexuels en deux malades
plutôt en personne en souffrance qu'il
convient d'aider ouais mais il ne soigne
pas les gens contre leur gré un que ce
soit dans une fois une volontaire il se
trouve que vous êtes infiltrez vous avez
dit vous vouliez participer vous avez
passé exactement alors c'est vrai
s'infiltrer dans la mafia corse comme si
vous étiez infiltrés dans les
alcooliques anonymes exactement nous
exempte d'ailleurs l'un des deux groupes
qu'on expose dans le livre est inspirée
clairement des alcooliques allemand va
bien que le séant sur lui-même
exactement donc là on serait tous les
sous les 6 autour de la table entre
chacun bonjour je m'appelle frédéric
ouais je suis attiré par les personnes
du même sexe voilà on n'est jamais chose
sexuelle jamais non parce qu'on n'est
pas homosexuel cependant de le
comprendre
ni l'identité profonde d'être
hétérosexuel et l'homosexualité est due
à une déviance seco spirituelle à des
blessures dans l'enfance un rapport
toxiques avec la mère ou le père mais
l'identité profonde dans ces groupes là
dans les théories de ces groupes là est
hétérosexuel oui mais justement à la
base il ya vraiment la question de
pourquoi est homosexuel oui c'était une
question qu'on n'a pas résolu
aujourd'hui certains disent bon on est
homosexuel d'autres pensent comme comme
eux qu'il s'est passé quelque chose qui
nous a rendus homosexuel alors il ya
deux choses il ya la question de
l'origine de l'homosexualité ya aussi la
question de la souffrance que ces
personnes-là récente wiki ces deux
questions qui sont liées en fait la
grande force de ces groupes là c'est
d'apporter une réponse qui est spirituel
donc par la prière par l' écoute mais
aussi de réponse qui va être ce que nous
on appelle pseudo psychologique parce
qu'on peut pas dire que c'est
psychologique comme réponse mais ça va
être des théories freudiennes date et ça
va être en interrogeant la personne sur
son rapport à son père son rapport à sa
mère en essayant de trouver en fait à
quel moment cette la dévier cette
déviance voilà exactement a vendu la
personne a provoqué des attirances
homosexuelles pour reprendre leur
lexique chez la personne mais c'est
typiquement américain on se sait cause
ndjili la l'homosexualité était encore
criminaliser jusqu'en 2002 1 et dans
certains états américains
c'est typiquement américain et on a vu
des films d'ailleurs souri aux hommes
mariés
il ne voulait évidemment pas avouer leur
homosexualité et allant voir des
psychiatres des psychanalystes pour se
guérir de leur musique alors qu'est-ce
sur cette question les etats unis sont
en avance entre guillemets parce que ce
phénomène il est connu chez autres puis
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps et en
fait sa société ses a aussi réagi à ça
c'est aujourd'hui aux etats-unis quand
on parle de thérapie de guérison on a
aussi des groupes qui vont défendre
al'inverse un discours critique de ces
thérapies là en fait on a des belles les
ex gay le mouvement ex gay donc des gens
qui pensent pouvoir guérir ou avoir
guéris de leur homosexualité
on va voir ce qu'on a en face c'est à
dire des ex ex gay sur des gens qui
dénoncent ces groupes-là par lesquels
ils sont souvent passées je pense
notamment à exodus qui a été l'un des
principaux groupes de thérapie de
guérison aux états unis dont le dernier
président aka
publié une lettre ouverte pour dire
voilà ça fait des années que je mens je
suis moi même homosexuel il est mort
elle est mariée avec un homme et il
s'est excusé demander pardon auprès de
tous les notamment les jeunes
homosexuels qui avaient pu être
traumatisé par sa sachant qu aux
etats-unis à des cas de suicide
donc c'est c'est beaucoup plus connu est
beaucoup plus traitées en fait mais ce
qu'il ya c'est de toute façon il n'a
rien de très étonnant tous les
monothéismes ont combattu
l'homosexualité depuis leur origine sur
le vent et cela continue avec le christ
l'abonné mais en revanche quand on met
un canton va commencer ce sujet avec mon
co auteur des deux rouleaux de la
première réponse qu'on avait au jour
activement par les c alors non ça
n'existe pas en france pas chez nous on
est au pays du mariage pour tous un pays
qui est relativement anticlérical quand
il faut le dire avec rire et qui a
dépénalisé le bouscat des analyses de
nos vallées gens sur cette personne est
le seul pays dans lesquels les
homosexuels n'ont jamais été inquiétés
pour leur homosexualité
et pourtant et pourtant ce qu'on trouve
ce qu'on avait dans le livre c'est que
c'est non seulement ces groupes là
existe donc pour te rendre vie c'est 95
à 395 qu'avant ça remonte
non seulement il existe mais en plus ils
sont en plein développement notamment
parce qu'ils ont pu se développer sous
le radar pendant 20 ans pour tandis
qu'il s'agit de 20 ans et demi rapporté
dans toutes les grandes villes
françaises maintenant mais la question
qu'on peut se poser après avoir lu votre
livre c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut leur
reprocher après tout les gens viennent
d'eux-mêmes tout abidjan un problème
mais ils n'ont pas envie d'être
homosexuel
regarde c'est comme ceux qui rompent eu
envie de fumer
si vous voulez ça les regarde moi ça
m'énerve mais alors ça et regarde c'est
une question qui nous a beaucoup animé
avec mon avec soit et la question de
qu'est ce qu'on leur reproche qu est-ce
qu est-ce qu on ne parle pas de maladies
font très attention à sûr mais bien sûr
mais parle de restaurer pas de ghetto
alors dans ce cas on est quand même sur
dans un certain qu'elle est quand même
sur une thérapie on est sur un exercice
j'avais pas illégal de la médecine dans
sûr parce que délais rapides y en a
plein diplo je prends l'exemple par
exemple de la session d'été que j'ai
fait l'année dernière pour laquelle je
vois sur infiltré pendant une semaine
s'agit d'une semaine où les gens vont
venir parler de leurs problèmes intimes
parler leur famille avec des histoires
qui sont parfois déchirante très lourde
et après cette semaine là donc qui est
faite de prière d'enseignements sur les
qualités intrinsèques de loeb et qu'elle
était en train ces deux femmes
en gros comment être un homme et comment
être une femme c'est ça l'idée quand ils
sortent de ces groupes là ce jour là il
se retrouve chez eux seuls
après une semaine entière
parler de leurs problèmes de leur vie de
deux voilà comment ça s'est passé avec
leurs parents de leur premier mari qui
les a battus pour les femmes et ça peut
être extrêmement violent de sortir de là
il se retrouver seul en fait et c'est ce
qu'on a notamment dans le livre on en
parle dans le documentaire qui partent
qui paraîtra sur arte en novembre on a
des points de vue de deux psychiatres
qui explique ce que c'est que la
décompensation justement dans ces
moments là et puis surtout parlé de
qu'est ce qu'on leur reproche non montre
si dans le livre que certains témoins
sorte de là avec des dépressions des
problèmes familiaux des tentatives de
suicide parfois aux états unis on a des
suicides clair et puis dans le temps le
cas des groupes que j'ai étudié on n'est
pas sûr de l'exercice mais on a aussi un
petit moins dans le livre quiquet qui a
subi huit exercices mais oui on est on
est quand même je vous mets ma main
j'avais un peu peur qu'on vous exhortons
exemple c'est vrai mais bon ce que je
veux dire par là que c'est au fond on
peut les attaquer pour escroquerie parce
qu'effectivement ils vous promettent
grosso modo vous allez redevenir un des
rôles sexuels
vous allez vous marier avec une femme
est rare des enfants on sait que c'est
une voie arrivé il ya eu par les temps
bien sûr elle est beaucoup d'hommes qui
ne voulant pas être homosexuels parce
que la pression sociale était trop de
fautes forte à leur encontre se sont
mariés oui alors probablement pas été
très heureux en ménage mais justement
sur ce point là où on regarde quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis quand on regarde les cantons
étudient les causes pourquoi ces jeunes
outsiders c'est moins jeunes se sont
parfois suicider ou il se suicide après
ces groupes là c'est parce qu'on leur
explique qu'il ya une possibilité de
changement
c'est ça le la racine quand même de
cette théorie là c'est de dire c'est
normal que tu te sens mal d'être
homosexuels parce que c'est pas normal
parce qu'il ya une défiance chez toi et
ensemble on va réussir à la la ça
revient parfois même sauf que quand on
essaye pendant des années une méthode
qui compte on nous dit qu'elle
fonctionne et qu'on se rend compte
qu'elle fonctionne pas c'est là que ça
peut devenir dangereux pour la santé
demande ou la camisole chimique qu'un va
inventer nos amis anglais
et là c'était une manière de punir les
homosexuels la chasteté
ah ça remonte à 65 exactement tout
encourage la plupart du temps exactement
alors je te renvoie les monothéismes
bien la chasteté fixée alors on est
encore en vie on est sur un groupe
évangélique pour courage il s'agit d'un
groupe catholique qui est lui accompagne
ses membres dans les enseignements du
christ à savoir pour les homosexuel le
fait de rester chaste et là le problème
est là la question de qu'est ce qu'on
leur reproche se pose parce que
effectivement et on le dit dans le livre
ces gens là ils sont là demain plein gré
moi j'ai pendant les infiltrations j'ai
croisé des hommes qui m'ont dit moi je
ne je refuse qu'on me dise de massue
mais voilà j'ai pas j'ai pas envie de
massue mais en tant qu'homosexuel c'est
mon problème ça m'emmerde
et effectivement c'est leur problème si
souvent vis des troubles sexuels à malte
déjà qui a interdit ces thérapies il ya
eu une proposition en franchissement est
ce que vous pensez pas qu'on a si
longtemps criminaliser le fait d'être
homosexuel que le de criminaliser aussi
aujourd'hui le fait de ne pas vouloir
l'être
est ce que ça vous paraît pas un peu
absurde alors pour ce qui concerne la
législation nous ce qu'on pense c'est
que c'est important de mettre l'accent
sur la victime de travailler sur la
victime en fait on est moi je ne pense
pas que dissoudre ces groupes par
exemple soit une idée qui soit une bonne
idée
notamment parce qu'ils vont continuer à
exister d'une prison du nôtre et qu'en
fait pour pouvoir agir il faut pouvoir
savoir qui ils sont et ce qu'ils font
dans les groupes donc sur la dissolution
on est plutôt partagée
en revanche ce qui nous paraît important
c'est de donner l'opportunité aux
victimes qui elles se sentent en
souffrance blessé traille arnaquer parce
que vous le directeur c'est cette
arnaque de leur donner la possibilité de
porter plainte d'être connu et entendu
en tant que victime et d'avoir un
travail judiciaire à partir du moment où
les victimes sont identifiées
dieu est amour le livre enquête de
jean loup est des nord et timothée de
rauglaudre est paru chez flammarion
[Musique]
cb line vous êtes auteur compositeur
interprète producteur
vous êtes le leader du groupe ithaque et
d'anarchistes république hobbies
vous parliez tout à l'heure mais je
propose pour qu'on fasse connaissance
on va regarder un extrait de votre clip
réalisé avec ithaque cette fois ci ça
s'appelle le jeu flight basten univers
là aussi on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sol se dérobe
[Musique]
cent ans
moi le spa
[Musique]
560 saveur
se découvre un vrai sens
[Musique]
le seigneur
gilles a
[Musique]
il
philippe douillet et ça vous aurez amusé
de travailler sur des ordinateurs comme
ça je vous voyais captiver j'ai
travaillé d ordinaire oui je sais mais
je n'ai aveyron je ne venais pas la
technique mais je sais ce que je veux et
c'est bien parce que y'a tout ce qu'on
vient de dire avant et à cette forme de
terreur qui nous est cette forme de
beauté ce absolue et et en plus ça
arrache un petit peu c'est bien ce
groupe vous l'avait appelée black c'est
l'acronyme de quoi ithaque parce que c'
it th
ak wayne ces instituts techno harmonique
de cordage cosmique c'était le bruit des
marques de voiture à l'origine c'est
sensé ça serait faire un peu je pense
que c'est gurdjieff c'est terminé je te
manque ici que c'était quelques galères
et perdu un oeil
ouais du cookie effet institut pour le
développement de l'homme je crois et
puis bon puis bon c'est du lys
évidemment et vous vouliez faire sans
musique venons je dirais que le nom
enfin pour être tout à fait franc les
initiales ont donné le nom après quoi
c'est d'abord de l'estrie drôle c'est
que vous êtes passé par l'ircam
ouais et alors normalement l'ircam on se
dit c'est pierre boulez c'est la musique
atonale je suis même passé par une école
d'ingénieurs donc oui je reviendrai en
fait derrière cam du besoin puis quoi
l'ircam déjà bon à l'époque avait pas
internet un document à l'ircam sam a
déjà ouvert les oreilles sur tout ce qui
était une musique contemporaine ligety
xenakis griset et compagnie
donc tous les jours j'étais à la
bibliothèque de dire qu'à écouter
écouter du son c'était une des plus
grosses bibliothèques on vie
contemporaine de france pense à elles et
ils m'ont appris après moi je
travaillais sur un sur ans louis chaix
appelé modalis donc ces synthèses pas
analyse modèle c'est un truc assez quand
tu auras pas rentrer dans les détails
mais voilà donc c'était une façon pour
moi de de clôture et ma carrière
inexistence d'ingénieurs et de
d'enchaîner sur une carrière musicale en
fait j'ai commencé par le rap je crois
alors ça je le faisais déjà pendant mes
études avant en maths sup maths spé
j'avais déjà un groupe de rap est un
groupe de hardcore en fait donc on sait
que le temps pour bosser les mains est
un mariage
vous avez été également influencé par la
musique ottomane
j'ai l'impression ouais bah je vécus en
fait j'ai vécu cinq ans à istanbul pour
2 pour des raisons privées fins
personnelles et donc effectivement je
suis tombé amoureux de cette musique de
cette culture de manière générale donc
j'ai beaucoup travaillé cette musique là
et donc j'ai intégré sans même le
vouloir consciemment mais c'est intégré
d'elle-même dans dans mon vocabulaire
musical donc hop hip hop hardcore
musique contemporaine peluches et de
musique contemporaine musique ottomane
ça peut donner on va regarder un extrait
de principe au lof réaction alors ça
c'est un album solo vous avez sorti il
ya un ou deux ans vous regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression quand on vous écoute
que vous avez fait la fusion de toutes
les musiques arabes et occidentales au
fond qui accumule par couche comme ça
sort pas cette prétention là mais c'est
une fusion par ni aussi des mélanges
histoire il ya une couche qui va se
rajouter donc au cours de ce concert du
5 mars puisque vous allez jouer avec ap
kim hamadouche qui joue du monde aux
luttes électrique qui accompagnèrent à
cheetah pendant 25 ans à peu près alors
là c'est encore une autre couche c'est
le chaâbi que vous rajoutez chaabi tous
afin que pour coup je connaissais très
peu en fait j'ai rencontré rachid sur la
fin de sa vie on était censé travailler
ensemble et donc rencontré hakim par
ricochet dont s'est tout de suite bien
entendu parce que lui aussi vient il a
toujours brune mélanger beaucoup de
musiques différentes touches abîmées
aussi avec le jazz ou le même le rock le
punk tout ça j'ai apprécié que le style
de notre époque musicalement c'est la
fusion en fait on n'a pas inventé de
nouvelles musiques depuis à peu près 25
ans donc on fusionne tout ce qui existe
en fait je crois que toutes les musiques
sont autant des fusions d'autres choses
de toute façon c'est ça se fait par ces
comme l'être humain on évolue par des
adn qui se mélangent fin n'y a pas donné
pas de nouvel être humain qui apparaît
d'un coup et c'est pareil je crois pour
la création artistique enfin je sais pas
pour vous mais moi personnellement je
suis influencé par dhimmi les artistes
est nourri par ça et c'est comme ça que
ça nouvelles choses secret et à quoi ça
va ressembler alors ce concert que
beaucoup de monde attend puisque la
rencontre des deux personnalités
laird excitez pas mal de monde ça va
être génial un peu comme la rencontre de
philippe druillet et veut françois avril
ouais bah ça va être surprenant je pense
enfin il n'y a pas d'image ya pas de son
nom mais rien tout va être créé l
institut du monde arabe
non mais
je suis premiers curieux de savoir
[Musique]
thomas schlesser donc vous êtes apte à
attaquer à une notion le faire rêver
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis le
xviiie siècle dit vous faire rêver vous
l'avez sous titré de l'art des lumières
au cauchemar publicitaire pourquoi parce
qu'au départ dit vous faire rêver c'est
assez noble c'était ambitieux et puis on
a fini par le prostitué
c'est exactement vous ayez quasiment
nous dégoûter de la notion de le faire
rêver vous expliquer comment elle
fonctionne en tout cas c'est vrai que
l'expression aujourd'hui en tant que tel
je le dis dans mon introduction
j'aimerais qu'elle soit aussi
désagréable que le crissement d'une
craie sur un tableau savent que c'est
une sorte de béquille qui sert
aujourd'hui vous dites prostitution
c'est un peu fort en tout cas un
dévoiement d'une ambition qui était très
noble parce que faire rêver c'est une
manière aujourd'hui je crois vraiment
surtout d'hypnotiser les foules et les
individus alors que dans un premier
temps au xviiie siècle
l'ambition de faire rêver et est
véritablement une ambition
d'émancipation donc d'ailleurs comme
souvent avec ce qui était l'idéal des
lumières quelque chose qui était très
positifs et qu'ils étaient en faveur
d'un mieux-être et bien je crois a
bifurqué s'est même effondré pour
devenir aujourd'hui quelque chose
d'insupportable
et si vous faites attention au nombre de
fois on entend cette expression dans
plein de contexte différent le procès
politique lui s'y perd le cinéma vous
apercevrez qu'en fait c'est un mot passe
partout maintenant le rêve mais qui a
des sous couvert d'avoir comme ça une
prétention très noble souvent c'est
vraiment pour aliéner les gens vous
donner un exemple celui de l'american
dream
oui le rêve américain au départ dit vous
là encore c'était dans un souci les
immigrants qui venait par millions aux
états unis
ab dans la voyez dans la notion de
l'american dream l'idée de l'égalité il
allait pouvoir être libres et égaux
il ne l'était pas dans leur pays
d'origine aujourd'hui c'est devenu le
rêve de repartir de las vegas avec
quelques billets de 100 dollars et une
blonde aux seins refaits sur les genoux
à pardon c'est encore pire que ça
puisque donald trump lui-même se sert
fréquemment du concept d' american dream
pour ce qu'il ya de pire c'est-à-dire
rejet raciste des mexicains et quantité
d'autres saloperies indigne mais dès
l'origine en fait le concept d' american
dream il né en 1931 précisément chez un
historien qui est pas connue en france
qu'à ma connaissance son ouvrage n'a
jamais été traduit et qui est vraiment
quelqu'un de très important dans les
années 30 aux états unis qui s'appelle
james lau adams et le livre en question
s'appelle vie épique of america l'épopée
de l'amérique est dedans en effet un
moment donné il dit c'est en conclusion
d'ailleurs de son ouvrage
il dit qu'en fait ce qui doit être
moteur mobiliser les américains c'est
vraiment ce rêve américain
mais dès le début et dit attention il
peut y avoir un écueil il faudrait pas
imaginer que le rêve américain
c'est simplement le rêve de hauts
salaires et de grosses voitures dans les
années trente et un résultat en effet ce
rêve a bel et bien tourné à ce que vous
disiez à l'instant oui alors c'est au
xviiie siècle que l'on commence à rêver
ou plutôt que le fait de faire rêver
devient un critère esthétique alors
c'est vous c'est exactement ça puisque
évidemment d'une part on a rêvé des
antiquités et même je dirais qu'on a
cherché à faire rêver d iliad et
l'odyssée ça va de soi en revanche ce
qu'il ya d'incroyable au xviiie siècle
c'est que l'idée qu'une oeuvre fasse
rêver commence à être considérée comme
un critère esthétique légitime pour le
faire très simple si vous voulez
jusqu'au 18e
je caricature un peu hein mais ce que
18e la fonction essentielle de la
cessoie une fonction édifiante ont lié
notamment à la religion ou au fait de
faire adhérer les individus
eu un message politique ou alors la
mission qu'on peut qualifier de
didactique informé instruire et c'est le
fait d'avoir tout à coup une évasion
libre par le biais de l'art non pas que
ce soit complètement exclue mais c'est
une strate beaucoup beaucoup plus
souterraine et qui commence
véritablement à si vous voulez à entrer
en action
au xviiie siècle et qui va ensuite alors
à léon saxena c'est juste devient mais
maintient c'est à ce moment là que
l'artiste et qui est en train de
remplacer l'artisan 1 et qui est en
train aussi de cesser d'être un
domestique
la plupart des artistes jusque là
étaient des domestiques des seigneurs il
leur faisait de la musique
il est il et les servait ils vont
commencer assez vont cibler et c'est
donc à ce moment-là que l'artiste est
celui qui a la capacité de nous faire
rêver
oui exactement et en particulier vous
avez un texte à la fin des années 1700
10 10 720 précisément où il y a donc le
premier peintre du roi le premier
peintre du roi ça veut dire là vraiment
la personne très très importante dans le
champ artistique s'appelle antoine
coypel il est pas très connu du grand
public aujourd'hui ils sont souvent
oubliés aller les premiers pas si c'est
vrai et antoine coypel dans un discours
dit en effet que il y a un tableau qui
est beau qui doit être bon parce qu'il
fait rêver et rêver agréablement et à ma
connaissance c'est la première
occurrence dans un discours académique
du fait que un artiste a pour mission de
faire rêver alors ce tableau qui est
apparu à côté de nous ce tableau de
chardin et l'enfant
comment ça s'appelle otto tombe c'est
une toupie tout simplement revoir c'est
la petite toupie qui est sur la table à
côté de lui
et alors pourquoi ce pourquoi ce tableau
est il si important c'est parce que ces
temps forts est en train de rêver à
cette toupie
regardez le en fait il est en train
d'être concentré sur ce petit élément
qui est très anecdotique simplement un
jouet un jour où pourrait-on dire
alors que à côté lui lé symbole du
savoir il ya des livres il ya la plume
dans l'encrier est en fête
ce tableau est bouleversant puisque
l'éducation de cet enfant passe par une
rêverie contemplative dans un jouet qui
tourne sur lui même aura joué qui tourne
sur lui-même
ça a l'air de rien comme ça mais en fait
c'est la matérialisation de quantité de
révolution au sens physique et au sens
politique et notamment une révolution
tout simple qui est celle de la
révolution cosmique
c'est à dire que à l'échelle même de
l'univers est bien dans une toupie
on peut avoir une idée de ce qui se
produit la course des planètes
donc il y à une sorte d'intuition du
savoir et d'un savoir universel dans la
simple rêverie devant un jouet c1 c'est
un un tableau absolument merveilleux
thomas schlesser si vous dites que c'est
au même moment d'ailleurs que les
l'habitat se fragmente qu'on va
commencer à habiter dans des
appartements et que jusque là nous
vivions tous dans la même pièce très
souvent d'ailleurs on dormait dans le
même lit et là tout à coup on va avoir
des chambres à coucher on va avoir des
boudoirs on va avoir des cabinets et
tout c'est tout ça ça se ferment à clé
on de s'enfermer derrière c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs pendant longtemps on
appellera les toilettes des cabinets et
ça aussi ça participe de la rêverie
mais c'est le cinéma c'est un évènement
considérable c'est à dire cette
évolution architecturale dont nous
sommes aujourd'hui même les héritiers
donc s'ils voulaient quand on parle du
xviiie siècle a à ce moment là il faut
bien comprendre que on en est le produit
un actuel c'est une fragmentation des
espaces et de fait une privatisation des
comportements pour le dire simplement
vous aviez un modèle ancien qui était
plutôt horizontale est ouvert et on va
passer un mot
dell qui est vertical est fermée jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les grands immeubles et en
effet du fait même qu'on ferme les
portes et qu'on les ferme à clé qu'on
ait des endroits spécialement pour pour
dormir
il peut y avoir une attention beaucoup
plus soutenue à notre intériorité à nos
sensations à notre intimité et de ce
fait une attention beaucoup plus
soutenue au rêve et à la rêverie et le
tableau de coraux qui est ici qui
représente c sérums et et notamment le
colisée localiser judée desjardins
farnèse
ouais
et pourquoi ce tableau participe-t-il de
dû faire rêver alors ça c'est un petit
peu plus tard mais c'est tout à fait
typique devant une oeuvre comme celle ci
il y a de la part de la critique
un engouement est le critère qui est
retenu c'est le fait que le tableau
fasse rêver c'est à dire sa beauté tient
au fait que devant lui
l'esprit peut s'évader peu divaguer
librement et par conséquent et bien
c'est un tableau qui en soi est de
qualité au nom de critères que moi
j'appelle l'oni roger né it et le fait
rêver au nitrogène qui fait rêver voilà
faire rêver de l'art des lumières au
cauchemar publicitaire c'est signé
thomas schlesser essai paru chez
gallimard dans la collection art et
artistes merci d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
non